eich hamdoune bonjour bonjour à vous
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
tôt ce matin sur rtl france alors on
s'en souvient c'était le 25 mai dernier
avec les égoutiers vous occupiez l'hôtel
de ville aujourd'hui vous menacé de ne
plus ramasser les déchets avant l'hégire
on lisait le bras de fer ça veut dire
qu'il continue donc avec la mairie de
paris tout à fait parce qu'il le
dialogue n'est a été revu ils ont passé
des lois à notre insu sans inviter dans
la table des négociations le syndicat
donc je ce qui est inadmissible
aujourd'hui les premiers concernés c'est
quand même les gens qui sont sur le
terrain et prendre des décisions sans
inviter le syndicat c'est pas moi c'est
vraiment inadmissible donc on a voulu
montrer par cette action que nous étions
encore là et qu'on avait encore il voit
et on apportait donc à jusqu'à l'autel
des vies c'était le seul moyen de nous
faire entendre et est donc ça a porté
ses fruits d'ailleurs alors pour pour
bien comprendre qu'elles sont très très
clairement les raisons de votre colère
aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui avec la loi
de la transformation de la fonction
publique
une loi qui qui fait en sorte que tous
nos acquis gagnés et jadis par par les
anciens sont peu à peu
donc retiré on veut nous allons jouer
notre temps de travail
alors qu'un éboueur vit en moyenne 12
ans de moins par rapport à par rapport à
la moyenne française et un égoutier 17
ans de moins et donc ils ne prennent pas
en compte ces considérations et ils
veulent nous allons geler notre travail
et où il nous mettra 25 jours de ca et
donc 25 jours par rapport à l'autre
notre implication et la santé compère au
boulot c'est pas assez
aujourd'hui on veut nos revendications
elles sont justes sont juste logique
nous vivons moins longtemps c'est normal
d'avoir un peu plus de partir plus tôt à
la retraite et de travailler moins que
nos revendications sont légitimes en
fait la ministre le ministre amélie de
montchanin c'est elle qui auteur de la
réforme est bien assuré qu'il y aurait
des exceptions à cette nouvelle loi
pour autant vous n'êtes pas rassuré non
bien sûr les policiers l'ont déjà montré
à maintes reprises que même ma mieux
actes et écrits noir sur blanc
ils reviennent sur leurs paroles donc
aujourd'hui ils nous remettent à chaque
fois ça tous les dix ans sur le tapi en
espérant que la mémoire soit courte et
que les nouveaux arrivés se battent - et
donc aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans
dans le manque de confiance parce que ça
a déjà été actée donc aujourd'hui on se
bat pour l'anc ont trouvé que on
n'oublie pas qu'on n'est pas amnésique
qu'à chaque fois ils essaient de nous
augmenter notre temps de travail
ils essayent de nous enlever nos rtt et
paient pas parler pour ses mouvements
par ces rassemblements on leur prouve
que voilà c'est impossible aujourd'hui
d'augmenter notre travail c'est contre
ben c'est contre la modernité on tend
plus aaa réduire le temps de travail qui
a elle augmenté tout le monde en europe
et partout dans le monde
or qui ça porte ses fruits de travailler
moins du coup quand on travaille moins
une recrue de plus et il ya une égalité
qui se fait alors qu'aujourd'hui
augmenter le temps de travail de déjà de
personnes qui sont déjà usées mon
travail dans la rue qui vendit neige qui
est là qu canicule on est on met notre
corps à toute épreuve
donc on veut juste une reconnaissance de
notre sens une reconnaissance et pas de
compromis donc aujourd'hui à vous
entendre on peut pas avoir de compromis
sur la santé la santé n'a pas on peut
pas négocier la santé aujourd'hui comme
je me dis allez voir vite 12 ou 12 ans
de moins que la moyenne france
elle égoutiers vie 17 ans de moins donc
on peut pas faire de compromis
on vous entend vous en êtes où
aujourd'hui les négociations vous disiez
que ça ça bougeait un petit peu ces
derniers jouaient ce que vous en met
donc le 25 mai après être rentré à
l'hôtel de ville
nous avons pu avoir conservé nos rtt
donc nos rtt été mises en misant
justement en fait les rtt devait être
mérité en fait si vous étiez présent au
travail vous pouviez donc à voir vos rtt
si jamais vous étiez malade en accident
de travail ou que vous posiez des
vacances donc vos rtt
sautez donc nous cette action du 25 mai
à l'hôtel de ville nous a permis de
conserver nos rtt mais aujourd'hui est
aussi drôle de rocard le dialogue avec
avec avec la hiérarchie et le syndicat
choses qui avaient été rompues et donc
nous attendons à ce que nous conservions
juste nous à qui on demande pas plus on
ne demande pas des choses
extraordinaires juste de garder ce qu'on
a actuellement alors à un rassemblement
est prévu d'ailleurs aujourd'hui encore
devant l'hôtel de ville dans quel état
d'esprit vous êtes avait avec vos
collègues vous ne lâcherai rien jusqu'au
jeux olympiques s'il le faut bien sûr de
toute façon nous avons le moyen de
pression aujourd'hui si jamais les
éboueurs ne ramassent pas les poubelles
ne balaye pas savez très bien que c'est
une action déjà visible ci ne serait ce
que deux jours ou trois jours les mets
ont les éboueurs ne sont pas sur le
terrain c'est visible donc aujourd'hui
nos actions continuent on est soutenu
par l'ensemble du territoire
donc on a plusieurs régions qui nous ont
apporté leur soutien donc on les
remercie pour ça et voilà donc on attend
1 que que aussi les parisiens ne
soutiennent pas ce que c'est aussi pour
qu'on se bat
pour une qualité de travail aujourd'hui
il nous manque énormément de monde sur
le terrain
et voilà nous demandons juste de
conserver nos acquis et des recrutements
parce qu'il ya énormément de manque donc
aujourd'hui on estime à peu près 300
éboueurs en moins sur le territoire sur
la région parisienne on veut qu'on roule
en vue du recrutement et avoir des
avoirs des conditions de travail
correctes donc avec du matériel de il ya
eu à l'effort fait par par la ville de
paris
mais il ya encore du chemin à faire
merci beaucoup à issam dinh d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl frange le rappelle vous êtes délégué
syndical cgt éboueurs de paris